bonsoir il est 18 heures si vous nous
rejoignez en direct bienvenue pour une
nouvelle édition du 7 8 l'aktu le
journal de la rédaction pour faire le
tour de l'actualité locale en un peu
moins d'une demi heure voici les
principaux titres en images un homme de
20 ans qui seraient impliqués dans les
violences de cet été attrapés devait
comparaître aujourd'hui au tribunal de
versailles alexandre constant jo c'est
son nom évoque lui une bavure policière
et parle de violence le jugement a
finalement été repoussée la mort c'est
festif en tout cas au mexique nous la
toussaint et symbole de retrouvailles
entre les ancêtres disparus et les
vivants une tradition bien loin de nos
pratiques à l'estaminet à magny les
hameaux vous en connaîtrez tous les
détails et puis si vous aimez la science
fiction la bande dessinée à rester avec
lui aussi ce soir pour cet entretien
avec laurent bidault dessinateur
installé à versailles et nous présente
dans son atelier le premier volet de
paradoxes aux éditions glénat une bande
dessinée d'anticipation un thriller sur
fond de voyage dans le temps l'image du
jour à présent c'est au crédit agricole
et qui se prépare à s'installer dans un
nouveau bâtiment à guyancourt en tout
cas pour le moment la première pierre a
été posée
l immeuble de bureaux baptisé alsace
grand place sur un campus a déjà
existant depuis 1978 il totalisera à
vingt mille mètres carrés de surface et
permettra de porter à 4800 le nombre de
salariés sur le site et livraison début
2015 avec le crédit agricole ambitionne
de créer un pôle technologique de pointe
sur ce site
alexandre constante zoo 20 ans devait
comparaître ce mercredi devant le
tribunal correctionnel de versailles
pour son implication dans les émeutes de
trappes en juillet dernier le jeune
homme est accusé de violence de
rébellion également à l'encontre de
trois policiers dans la nuit du 19 au 20
juillet lui parle de bavure de coups et
d'insultés également le procès n'a pas
eu lieu il a été reporté comme nous
l'expliquent yolaine thorez et patrick
jacques de dixmude
la justice a décidé de prendre son temps
dans la sphère des émeutes de trappes le
procès d'alexandre constante zoo est
renvoyé pour cause de complexité et de
connexité avec d'autres éléments
une audience relais est prévue le 5
février 2014 pour faire le point un
renvoi qui satisfait le syndicat unsa
police
pour son secrétaire cela laisse plus de
pour mener les investigations poussées
et prouver que le jeune homme a
participé aux émeutes de juillet dernier
on va clairement pouvoir prouver que
cette personne était là que la parole
des fonctionnaires est clair et net et
qu'il n'y a pas eu de violences id
premièrement illégitime et deuxièmement
qu'ils n'ont fait que essayer de
repousser des individus qui voulaient
attaquer le commissariat alexandre
constante zoo 20 ans est soupçonné de
violences et de rébellion à l'encontre
des trois policiers tous partie civile
dans la nuit du 19 au 20 juillet une
version démentie par le jeune homme lui
se dit victime d'une bavure policière
il dit avoir été violentée et s'est vu
prescrire 45 jours d'itt et et son
avocat évoque des éléments soient
erronées soit mensongers de la part des
policiers et parle d'une couverture
fabriquer dès la deuxième heure après
l'arrestation
où on a en a une version qui est sa vie
alexandre badauds qui rendent une soirée
qui voit d'échauffourées à 2 cm qui
descend de sa voiture qu'il est son
portable qu'il est ses amis dans la
voiture donc il n'avait que pour
quelques minutes et qui se retrouvent
in an dans un guet-apens un autre
prévenu madjid 18 ans comparaît mercredi
prochain lui aussi est soupçonné de
violences et de rébellion à l'encontre
des policiers
alors que le débat a glissé maintenant
sur le droit du sol pour obtenir la
nationalité française avec les récentes
déclarations de jean françois copé qui
souhaite en finir avec cette disposition
europe ecologie les verts demande au
gouvernement de faire revenir leonarda
avec l'ensemble de sa famille tous
expulsés vous le savez car sans papiers
à la formation pourtant membre de la
majorité appellent les lycéens et les
étudiants à manifester encore et
toujours en soutien à l'adolescente de
15 ans le 5 novembre justement ils
seront dans la rue à l'appel
entre autres de l'unef syndicat
universitaire sur ces images la dernière
mobilisation de jeunes juste avant les
vacances à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis le mouvement dans la rue s'est
assagi et l'on en vient à notre question
du jour pour vous faire réagir vous le
savez à l'actualité comprenez vous cette
mobilisation des jeunes des lycéens
étudiants autour de la sphère de
l'expulsion de léonard da au micro de
jonathan willeman pense que il ya des
lois il faut les respecter un point
c'est tout pas vraiment non pourquoi
parce que je trouve que c'est hors la
loi entre guillemets je suis tout à fait
pour ne pas jeter des immigrés à la rue
mais là ça me semble excessif
cette situation est quand même anormal
le père a entre guillemets truander et
on va bientôt préféré donner raison à
des familles qui sont hors la loi qui
sont hors du système par rapport aux
familles françaises entre guillemets et
croyez moi je ne vote pas front national
loin de là à passer je comprends très
bien
des incompréhensions qui sont dans leur
coeur par rapport à ces jeunes filles
qui se fait expulser alors qu'elle a
fait qu'elle travaille bien lagarde est
bien dans ses baskets visiblement désire
revenir chez nous on peut comprendre
tout à fait que les étudiants les
lycéens aient envie que cette jeune
fille revienne faire ses études en
france
humainement parlant peut tout à fait le
comprendre si au moment de la
réalisation sur france télé le tour de
france avéré louper le passage devant le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
où vous l'aviez peut-être remarqué l'an
passé elle ne pourra en tout cas pas se
rattraper en 2014 en effet le 27 juillet
prochain
la dernière étape partira d'evry dans
l'essonne pour rallier les
champs-elysées pourtant sur les sept
dernières éditions l'ultime et âme à
l'ultime étape avait traversé les
yvelines à quatre reprises sur cette
101e édition dont le départ sera donné
le 5 juillet et depuis l'angleterre le
peloton parcourir à plus de 3600 km les
coureurs devront traverser l'enfer des
pavés du paris-roubaix sorti indemme est
de cinq arrivées au sommet 50 ans après
le duel mythique anquetil poulidor on
saura enfin si chris froome sera le
premier coureur à conserver sa couronne
depuis 1995 et l'espagnol miguel
indurain
me considère pas comme un prétendant
vraiment au podium donc j'aurais sans
doute pas le même stress que les que les
vraiment les poires favori mais ça sera
une étape où il peut y avoir de la casse
hoyaux rappaz y aura pas de leader qu à
gagner du temps mais des videurs qui
vont à perdre il y en aura c'est sûr et
certain que sa soif d'une manière
physique ou alors des sur des briques
matériel vois ça c'est sûr à 100
indiquant ne pas trop mais bon c'est
quand on est la dernière étape ça on n'y
pense plus c'est surtout
passé la ligne et voilà quoi et non non
c'est vrai que cette année au château de
versailles c'était vraiment joli et mais
bon comme jeudi les organisateurs y en
faut pour tout le monde tout le monde à
tout le monde veut sa vie des tables
donc voilà propos recueillis par anthony
rech alors qu'aujourd'hui était donc
dévoilé le parcours du tour de france
2014 2014 les yvelinois qui pourront
tout de même se consoler avec le paris
nice aussi en mars prochain qui devrait
partir selon nos informations de
montigny le bretonneux
à l'occasion des vacances de la
toussaint l'estaminet de magny les
hameaux célèbre la fête des morts à la
mode mexicaine pour l'occasion des
ateliers créatifs sont organisés pour
les enfants et les petits peuvent
confectionner des têtes de mort colorés
et des listes des squelettes
le tout dans une ambiance pourtant
joyeuse comme le veut la tradition au
mexique reportage d'olivier maniscalco
et 2 jonathan friedmann pour la
toussaint l'estaminet de magny les
hameaux rend hommage à ses morts à la
mode mexicaine traditionnelles
d'amérique centrale la fête des morts
célèbres en famille les ancêtres
disparus
malgré son nom c'est une fête joyeuse
les mariachis viennent jouer de la
musique dans les maisons décorées de
fleurs et ont relevé au squelette et
leurs plus beaux habits bon que lors
aussi des têtes de mort comme ce matin
dans cet atelier les enfants seront peu
créatif avec leurs crânes en terre cuite
géant prenez pas tout en blanc après je
vais jetter une bouche jaune
et des motifs orange et bleu c'est une
initiative qui a été prise par
l'estaminet de célébrer la fête des
morts un peu autrement et de donner une
connotation avec une autre accès à une
autre culture qui était la culture
mexicaine
il ya une exposition frida kahlo en ce
moment à paris et donc on avait aussi
envie de faire un lien par rapport àça
ouvrir un peu les gens ici sur une autre
dimension culturelle car les dimensions
pour halloween
jusqu'à vendredi les enfants auront
l'occasion de découvrir cette fête
méconnu via d'autres ateliers créatifs
crâne en sucre un des morts est
projection d'un film sur le thème
viendront agrémenter leur culture
mexicaine djembé batucada et steeldrums
des instruments de percussion et les 7
15 ans ont appris à les apprivoiser lors
d'ateliers qui était proposé à la
verrière yvelines torres voyages aux
quatre coins du monde à la verrière
durant deux jours à l'espace aimé
césaire accueille des enfants de 7 à 15
ans pour des ateliers percussions au
programme la batucada ce genre de
musique brésilien aux proches de la
samba se jouent avec des instruments
utilisés lors des carnavals
dans un tout autre style à quelques
mètres de là certains s'initie à la
tradition africaine du djembé autour
dans les années 20 aux caraïbes
ici on joue du steel drum à zéro
explique l'histoire de cet instrument
l'un des seuls exemples de révolution
par la musique les anglais ils ont
envahi les îles et que les habitants ils
ont été tous tués et subsistent en
esclavage pouvait plus faire de musique
alors ils ont trouvé des bidons et ils
ont ils ont qu'à bosser ça fait cet
instrument fabriqué à partir de bidons
de pétrole est accessible à tous et ne
nécessite aucune connaissance musicale
l'enseignement est orale on n'a pas de
partition rien du tout les notes sont
indiquées sur les instruments et puis
ben voilà c'est la mémoire qui va
travailler et puis l'apprentissage de
l'oreille direct
il n'y a pas de partition est laissé
entre eux celui qui guide le professeur
et puis les élèves qui vont qui vont se
servir aussi de leurs propres moyens des
camarades et puis essayer à chaque fois
d'avoir quelque chose de cohérent
nous poursuivons ce journal du 23
octobre partant à présent à versailles à
la rencontre de laurent bidault
dessinateur il vient de terminer
paradoxe ouvrage d'anticipation aux
éditions glénat il travaille déjà sur le
second volet et nous a ouvert la porte
de son atelier c'est l'entretien de
cette édition
oh
on
nous savons en compagnie d'un
dessinateur aujourd'hui laurent bidault
à versailles les dessinateurs de cette
bande dessinée paradoxe édité par glénat
scénarisé par didier convard bonjour
laurent bidault merci de me recevoir
chez vous dans votre atelier c'est ici
que vous travaillez paradoxe premier
tome qui vient de sortir en librairie
c'est de la science fiction 2034 à être
vers conrad un homme qui est capable de
voyager entre des univers parallèles
pouvez nous en dire un peu plus sur
cette histoire mais c'est une histoire
effectivement de science fiction mais
avec une grande part du récit qui se
situe aujourd'hui et doit être conrad
est en fait diplômés du supra physique
on va même dire prix nobel duprat
physique mais il est très controversée
et effectivement il a la capacité de se
déplacer longtemps mais de se cloner en
fait dans le temps et le tout pour
sauver sa femme en fait il s'est
présenté comme un ouvrage d'anticipation
c'est à dire que vous y croyez à ses
possibilités ses évolutions ses bases et
aussi sur une sur une histoire vraie sur
une expérience on est un petit peu qui
avait permis à des scientifiques de ceux
de dépasser la vitesse de la lumière en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il pensait ça a été
ensuite contredit l'année suivante en
2012 mais en 2011 on y croyait c'est ça
qui a lancé l'histoire
effectivement ris c'est l'idée de départ
de pour le scénariste ça lui a permis de
se dire tiens ici en se déplaçant dans
le temps ont laissé une double de soi
même s'étendre en larmes et
effectivement ça permet d'avoir un
scénario extrêmement malin intelligent
et retors justement ces rotors c'est
compliqué comme comme scénario est ce
que du coup ça rend compliqué
l'illustration
les dessins parce qu'il faut rester
aussi fluide pour la compréhension du
lecteur on voyage entre les époques on
voit ce personnage parfois se rencontrer
lui même aussi donc il faut faire
attention à la façon dont il vieillit
pour que ça reste crédible mais il ya
énormément de difficultés dans cette
bande dessinée parce qu'il faut à la
fois effectivement être clair donc j'ai
utilisé un style de trail ligne claire
et
effectivement faire attention à tous les
détails tous les raccords il faut que
les personnages on les voit vieillir on
les sent vieillir et que les vêtements
aussi expriment les changements d'époque
des changements de style très précis
l'anticipation globalement c'est quelque
chose qui vous intéressent qui vous
fascine ou pas vous allez payer mais par
sa mère jusqu'à présent j'étais plutôt
is verser dans la bande dessinée
historique
c'est une nouveauté pour moi mais c'est
passionnant oui mais il faut être très
précis faut être très très bien détaillé
son travail ça veut dire qu'un échange
permanent avec le scénariste comment
vous avez travaillé sur sur ce livre je
sais que vous vous disiez vous expliquer
que c'est sans doute le livre qui vous a
est la bande dessinée qui vous a mené
ces sites demandé le plus de travail sa
nécessité peu plus d'un an de travail
c'est ça tout à février jusqu'à présent
j'étais scénariste de mes propres
ouvrages mes propres bandes dessinées
donc là de travailler avec didier
convard qui est un très grand scénariste
de la bande dessinée aujourd'hui j'ai
voulu être respectueux de son travail et
donner beaucoup plus que ce que je ne
donnais jusqu'à présent même si c'est
déjà beaucoup de travail donc là au lieu
d'un an j'ai passé un an et demi voire
un peu plus pour créer ces univers c'est
puis en plus surtout il ya des lieux il
ya un nombre de personnages
considérables sous les doigts il
commandera de travail en équipe donc qui
dit qu'il dit multiplicité de le
personnage a dessiné à créer et à
concevoir
je travaille avec le scénariste
justement vous qui étiez habitué à
scénariser vos propres votre propre
bande des six mais là ça change un petit
peu c'est plus contraignant comment vous
avez vraiment travailler un échange
permanent où il vous livre un scénario
et c'est à vous de l'illustré en collant
au mieux à ces demandes alors c'est un
peu des deux en fait on se connaît très
bien avec didier le scénariste donc jeu
respecte à la lettre son scénario qui
est très très bien détaillé lui-même
était dessinateur dans une première
carrière
donc il sait parfaitement ce que le
dessinateur à temps il est très
respectueux et vice versa de son travail
donc on est à la fois complémentaires
tout en nous sachant que le travail de
l'autre enrichi de travail du collègue
vous travaillez plus techniquement
peut-être vous dessinez tous ici vous
revenez ensuite vous travaillez par
ordinateur comment ça se passe votre
travail de dessinateur
il ya un peu des deux j'ai aussi fait
des reportages sur place puisqu'elle le
lutetia dans le tome 1 qui apparaît il
ya aussi différents quartiers de paris
que j'ai voulu voir précisément pour
préparer sa valise on fait des croquis
vous est un peu les goûts de photos
surtout donc des photoreportages pour
visualiser géographique pour précisément
les lieux et ensuite
oui je dessine ici d'abord un premier
story board qui permet de mettre en
place les cases les personnages dans les
cases puis ensuite un long travail de
dessin ensuite ces dessins sont scannés
sur l'ordinateur intégré dans la mise en
page
ensuite on crée ensuite mis en colère
vous parlez de la ligne claire dans des
centres et ligne au clair en ce qui
concerne cette bande dessinée votre
travail ce qui vous inspire justement
comme comme moteur comme classique de la
bd franco belge est ce qu'il ya des
auteurs qui ont guidé un petit peu vos
débuts de dessinateurs et vous inspire
disons que will et les grands classiques
moi j'avais beaucoup william vance des
six qui dessinent 13 il a un style très
efficace très épuré plein plein
d'énergie enfant j'avais beaucoup les
tuniques bleues l'entente ils vont
certainement à un moment donné envie de
faire avant décidé donc c'est assez
éloigné de ce que je fais aujourd'hui
mais sont des bandes dessinées
classiques franco belge de l'énergie de
l'égalité vous n'êtes pas avare en
explications sur votre travail parce que
vous avez même un blog
déjà vous nous recevez vous livrer un
petit peu votre travail tous les
dessinateurs ne le font pas certains
bien travailler seul et même un blog où
vous expliquez vous montrer un petit peu
comment évolue le travail ça toujours
été un choix pour vous oui oui tout à
fait aujourd'hui bon dessinateur ça
travaille tout seul
hélas ou avec grâce à tous ces moyens
aujourd'hui email facebook blogs ça
permet d'avoir une fenêtre ouverte à la
fois sur son éditeur sur les lecteurs
sur les proches où tout le monde perd
mais ça permet à tout le monde
finalement de suivre l'évolution du
travail et d'en mesurer la longueur
elle a actuellement vous travaillez
forcément sur le deuxième tome parce que
paradoxe ce sera en trois ouvrages le
premier a été publié en fin septembre on
est donc au tout début de sa mise en
vente mais vous travaillez déjà sur la
suite exactement le comment devenir ses
personnages mais si on peut faire des
révélations peut-être effectivement ces
personnages d'un rayon de personnages
je veux pas trop en révéler
non plus la du tome 2 mais je suis moi
je découvre petit à petit le scénario et
je dois avouer que c'est très prenant
même pour le dessinateur
le scénario est terminée oui dont vous
êtes à quelle étape vous en êtes où un
petit peu dans dans la préparation
là j'en suis à la planche 23 24 et je
travaille sur le storyboard et puis le
dessin au fur et à mesure ça veut dire
que vous avez mis toutes les autres
créations tous vos autres travaux en
suspens où vous travaillez parallèlement
sur d'autres ouvrages
oui effectivement là je travaille avec
un auteur renommé lucien rollin sur une
bande dessinée sur le gouffre de padirac
donc c'est une histoire sur la
spéléologie au 19e siècle et c'est
passionnant mais là je suis seulement
scénariste 20 seulement des guillemets
et on reste sur l'historique est vrai
mais moi j'ai découvert la spéléologie
et les origines de la spéléologie grâce
à ce scénario est basse et c'est en fait
si ce personnage et au 19e siècle en
fait ils étaient tournés vers le futur
c'est intéressant de découvrir ça merci
laurent bidault nous avoir reçus ici
dans votre dans votre atelier on va vous
laisser à présent travailler continuer
la suite de paradoxe le deuxième volume
le premier en tout cas est déjà
disponible en librairie et c'est édité
par glénat
samedi et dimanche se tenait à gaz rend
une exposition sur les champignons
l'occasion pour les visiteurs de
découvrir d'en découvrir un petit peu
plus sur les quelques 200 variétés qui
existe l'occasion surtout d'en apprendre
un peu plus sur la toxicité de certaines
espèces
en cette période propice à la cueillette
au vivier maniscalco anthony rech
apprendre à cueillir sans danger les
champignons
c'est le thème que proposait ce week-end
et l'exposition mycologique de gaz rend
organisé depuis plusieurs années par le
centre d'études de rambouillet et de sa
forêt l'expo proposé aux visiteurs
d'observer près de 220 espèces de
champignons girolles cèpes de bordeaux
chanterelle en tube ou trompettes de la
mort certains champignons se consomme
sans risque pour d'autres il faut être
bien plus vigilants le conseil déjà
qu'on va donner en premier c'est de bien
cueillir l'intégralité du champignon
parce que si on n'a pas les
caractéristiques de la base du pied on
peut passer à côté d'une amanites avec
une vole donc bien cueillir
l'intégralité du champignon alors voilà
donc la manif phalloïde qu'il faut bien
apprendre à connaître puisque c'est
vraiment la plus dangereuse avec une vol
vensac très épaisse un halo et surtout
les verdâtre avec des fibres et sur le
chapeau mais elle peut aussi être
blanche
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut bien
accueillir tout le champignon pour avoir
la volt de blanc l'a touché non non non
par contre
un tout petit bout la moitié du chapeau
je ne croyais pas plus de champignons en
fait parce que depuis trois ans que j'ai
découvert cette cette exposition je
trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de champignons
qui se ressemblent trop et donc j'ai
peur de me tromper si je ne suis pas
accompagner par quelqu'un de compétent
près de deux mille variétés de
champignons ont été inventoriés sur le
massif de rambouillet selon le ser
foulée cas d'intoxication sont en
augmentation ces derniers temps prenez
donc le temps de vous renseigner ou de
faire appel
un mycologue avant vos sorties en forêt
si vous êtes amateurs du psg en football
sachez que le 18 octobre dernier le
conseil régional d'île de france a voté
un amendement déposé par europe ecologie
les verts interdisant la création d'un
espace vert et de loisirs sur le plateau
d allumer le roi un site pressenti pour
accueillir le futur centre
d'entraînement du club de la capitale
une décision saluée par la confédération
paysanne qui rappelle que moins de 50%
des ter un francilien sont aujourd'hui
des espaces agricoles les dirigeant
qatari n'ont pas réagi
on ne sait pas quel score sera prise la
décision de déménager le camp des loges
actuellement à saint germain la base de
loisirs de saint quentin serait toujours
en course mais sans plus de précisions
la piste on notera aussi que
clairefontaine a modifié en urgence son
plan d'occupation des sols en plan local
d'urbanisme cela signifie que la voie
est ouverte à la rénovation du centre
technique national de football des
démolitions reconstructions sont au
programme pour une partie de ce site une
décision prise dans la précipitation
alors qu'approche la coupe d'europe ce
sera en 2016 en france
on revient à l'information principale du
jour s'il n'était pas avec nous au début
de cette édition alexandre costanzo à 20
ans devait comparaître ce mercredi
devant le tribunal correctionnel de
versailles pour son implication dans les
émeutes à trappes en juillet dernier
seulement le procès a n'a pas eu lieu
mais il a été reporté
comme nous l'expliquent sur place sur
les torres patrick jacques de dixmude
la justice a décidé de prendre son temps
dans la sphère des émeutes de trappes le
procès d'alexandre constante zoo est
renvoyé pour cause de complexité et de
connexité avec d'autres éléments
une audience relais est prévue le 5
février 2014 pour faire le point un
renvoi qui satisfait le syndicat unsa
police
pour son secrétaire cela laisse plus de
temps pour mener les investigations
poussées et prouver que le jeune homme a
participé aux émeutes de juillet dernier
on va clairement pouvoir prouver que
cette personne était là que la parole
des fonctionnaires est clair et net et
qu'il n'y a pas eu de violences
premièrement illégitime et deuxièmement
qu'ils n'ont fait que essayer de
repousser des individus qui voulaient
attaquer le commissariat alexandre
constante aux 20 ans est soupçonné de
violences et de rebellions à l'encontre
des trois policiers tous partie civile
dans la nuit du 19 au 20 juillet une
version démentie par le jeune homme lui
se dit victime d'une bavure policière
il dit avoir été violentée et s'est vu
prescrire 45 jours d'itt et et son
avocat évoque des éléments soient
erronées soit mensongers de la part des
policiers et parle d'une couverture
fabriquer dès la deuxième heure après
l'arrestation
où on a en a une version qui s'habille
alexandre badauds qui rendent une soirée
qui voit des échauffourées à 250 mètres
qui sont sa voiture qu'il est son
portable qu'il est ses amis dans la
voiture dont il n'avait que pour
quelques minutes qui se retrouvent
et non dans un guet-apens un autre
prévenu madjid et 18 ans comparaît
mercredi prochain lui aussi est
soupçonné de violences et de rébellion à
l'encontre des policiers
fin de ce journal toutes nos éditions
sont à retrouver sur notre site internet
rubrique le 7-8 l'aktu la rédaction vous
donne rendez vous demain 18h en direct
pour faire le tour de l'information
locale ce mercredi
n'oubliez pas que ce que le magazine
culturel avec aurélia de lui si à demain